do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a teaser breakdown video as I'm sure
most of you know by now HBO was set to
reveal the premiere date right before
the new episode of True detective begun
now I know that all of us were hoping
they would release a trailer at the same
time but unfortunately they did not
however they did release another teaser
for their final season and this time it
was a teaser for Winterfell I don't know
about you but this one got me very
excited this one was filmed exclusively
in the crypts of Winterfell and one
thing that I noticed which I think is
very interesting is we did not see bran
stark and the teaser we saw Jon sanso
and Arya along with their statues but
there was no sign of their brother bran
that definitely piques my curiosity but
let's dive into the teaser and discuss
some of the things that we did see I did
watch it two times before I started
making the video so please bear with me
I am still trying to piece together the
information as we speak there will most
likely be some tinfoil ideas tossed
around in the video as well mainly
because of how this teaser actually
ended let's start at the very beginning
as you can see the teaser begins with a
shot of Jon Snow walking through the
crypts of Winterfell one of the very
first things we see is Jon walking past
his mother lay on a statue as Jon walks
right past her statue we can hear Leona
tell Ned you have to protect him now
this part of the teaser did not really
surprise me that much
we know that this has been a major part
of John's story the identity of Jon's
mother has been kept a secret for a very
long time but over the past couple
seasons they have started to reveal
exactly who Jon's parents are which we
know are Rhaegar and Lyanna we also
found out last season that they got
married right before John was born
therefore this makes Jon a legitimate
Targaryen and next in line for the Iron
Throne this was one of the biggest
reveals in the television show today but
Jon still doesn't have any eye
eeeh who he truly is think about how
many times John may have actually walked
past Leon a statue without having a
single clue that she is actually his
mother so we all know this is something
John will find out next season when he
finally returns to one turf oh and
speaks what bran I know that this is one
scene that I am highly anticipating I
imagine when John finds out he will go
down into the crypts of Winterfell to
see his mother statue they showed John
walking past it as a tease but I
guarantee we will see John down here
standing in front of her statue now
knowing who he truly is after John does
pass her statue we can see that the
feather has fell from her hand onto the
floor and if you remember that was the
feather we saw robert baratheon placing
her hand all the way back in the very
first episode of the show this will not
be the last time we see the feather and
the teaser but let's move on to the next
scene next we can see Lady Sansa walking
through the crypts of Winterfell and as
she's walking we can see her walk past
her mother statue then we can hear one
of Lady catlins quotes
she says all this horror that has come
to my family Catelyn said this during a
conversation she was having with Robb
Stark's wife to Lisa this was when
Catelyn was talking about Jon Snow this
was in reference to her saying that she
could not find it in herself to love a
motherless child as we all know when Ned
brought John home Catelyn hated him so
much that she actually wanted him to die
but take a look at John now he might end
up saving how start from going extinct
so it's probably a good thing that Jon
didn't end up dying as a baby anyways
another reason why I think they might
have shown Sansa walked past her mother
statue is because Catelyn Stark was once
the lady of Winterfell but now that
title has moved on to her daughter Sansa
Stark as I've said in some of my
previous videos I believe Sansa will
continue to hold that title even though
John might have been the king in the
north and even the king of the Seven
Kingdoms depending on how you want to
look at it I have a very good feeling
Sansa will continue to have full control
of Winterfell while John focuses most of
his energy on commanding the armies and
hopefully protecting the castle the next
person we see in the teaser is Arya
Stark and it doesn't appear as if she's
walking past any specific statues but
she is also down in the crypts of
Winterfell with John and Sansa after
they briefly show Ari
we go back to John but this time he is
standing in front of Ned Stark statue
then we can hear Ned say you are a Stark
you might not have my name but she had
my blood this is yet again another
reference to John Snow and it's also
another hint about John's parents this
is obviously one of the major themes
throughout the final season now as we
all know there are a lot of important
characters in the show but only one of
them are the Song of Ice and Fire and
that is Jon Snow so far all the quotes
that we have heard in the teaser are in
reference to Jon not only is he the true
heir to the Iron Throne but Jon will
most likely have to be the one to face
the night king in a 1vs1 battle to the
death
it's quite clear that these two
characters are drawn to each other for a
reason and if you've been watching most
of my Theory videos then you would know
exactly why the night king has such an
attraction to hell stark but I will
discuss this further here in a little
bit let's move on to the next few images
and the teaser now I was actually
surprised by the next part this is when
we see Jon Arya and Sons a halt meet up
in the center of the crypts of
Winterfell this is the first time we
have seen Jon and Arya in the same shot
since the first season of the show I was
not expecting them to give us this
reveal before the season started this is
one of the most highly anticipated
reunions in the show but they did give
us a big taste of what's to come getting
to see Jon and Arya standing next to
each other as pretty damn cool I must
say after they all meet up in the center
we then see them turn around where it is
revealed that all three of them have
statues made down there as well
now I know that some people could see
this as foreshadowing their deaths
however that is definitely something
they would want us to think we do know
from the books that all future members
of House Stark have empty tombs down
there but what's interesting about this
is if you look at the statues you can
tell that they were freshly made it does
make me wonder what will happen to each
of these characters because there
certainly is a possibility that all of
them could die we know that Winterfell
is one of the Night Kings targets and
this teaser even hints about his
presence in the location as Jon Sean's
and Arya are looking at their statues
the cold air begins to creep into the
crypts of Winterfell we even see Liana's
feather one more time only
this time we can see that it freezes
which means that the night King is
definitely getting very very close but
now I want to go into some tinfoil
before we go any further could this also
mean that something else is down there
in the crypts
for many many years fans have speculated
that perhaps the night's Queen is locked
up down there in one of the lowest
levels there is also a possibility that
one of the previous night Kings is kept
down there as well not only are there a
ton of connections between the Starks
and the White Walkers but there are also
hints about what could be kept down
there and some of the statues in the
very first book Ned Stark has a dream
and what he sees down there is very
interesting this is what it says he was
walking through the crypts beneath
Winterfell as he had walked a thousand
times before the Kings a winner watched
him pass with eyes of ice in the
direwolves at their feet tongue their
great stone heads and snarled now I know
it is a very short quote but one thing
that stands out to me is the description
of their eyes it says the kings of
winter had eyes of ice now who else do
we know has eyes of ice that would be
the others or the White Walkers this
quote alone has always made me wonder
who those kings of winter actually are I
tend to believe that at least one of
them could be the former night's king
who old man did say was a member of
House Stark you also have to keep in
mind when turf L was built right around
the time that the long night ended
before the castle was even build the
first thing that was established were
the crypts of Winterfell since their
castle was called Winterfell you have to
ask yourself if that could be in
reference to a king of winter falling in
that location and by king of winter I am
of course referring to a night king you
also have to keep in mind that even the
television show has hinted that there
may have been more than one night king
over time we know what the current night
king looks like but we have also seen a
painting in one of the caves on
Dragonstone and I think most people
would agree that they do not look alike
this also lends to the theory that maybe
you can't defeat the night king only
replace him so going back to the teaser
what did the cold mist actually
represent was that just simply a warning
that the night king was coming to
Winterfell
or does it hint at something else being
down there in the crypts if there is
something down there locked up in the
low
could that be what the night king is
coming after another thing it could be
suggesting is perhaps those statues
actually come alive and fight during the
big battle in the north there are also a
bunch of hints about this and the books
as well imagine if the knight King was
able to raise all of the dead Starks
below Winterfell that would be
absolutely terrifying and I think it
could be possible but let's continue so
as we see the mist rolling into the
crypts this is when Jon Arya and Sansa
all turn around to see where it's coming
from as they turn around we can see that
Jon and Arya both pull out their swords
now as we all know Sansa does not have a
weapon but what's interesting is saans
is slightly standing behind Jon and REO
it almost looks as if they're protecting
her kind of like her queen's guard at
the moment
what makes this scene so cool is we
actually see Jon and arias stand-in side
by side with their weapons drawn ready
to fight this is an image I've been
dying to see for so long and we all knew
this day would eventually come and it is
almost here ladies and gentlemen on
April 14th the first episode of the
final season will premiere and this is
when we will get our official reunion
with Jon and Arya then in just a few
short episodes by mid-season we will
actually see Jon and Arya have to defend
Winterfell from an attack by the night
king now this is something we all knew
what happened or at least I did because
for over a year I have been telling you
that the big battle against the night
king would take place and Winterfell
but what really intrigues me about the
teaser is that damn mists down in the
crypts I seriously feel like it could
mean so many different things and I
don't even know where to begin
other than what I mentioned already like
I said I just watched the video two
times before I started making this video
immediately and I will need to watch it
a few more times that way I can kind of
let my thoughts digest a little bit
hopefully I said a few things already
that will spark a good conversation down
in the comments section of the video let
me know what you thought about the
teaser this one got me even more excited
than the last one but let me know what
you think
do you believe anything white Walker
related is down in the crypts of
Winterfell or do you think that the
knight Cain could possibly raise all the
dead Starks down below anyways I want to
thank you all for watching the video I
really appreciate that and I also want
to thank all of my patreon
members for supporting the channel
through the long nights I hope everyone
has a great night I will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
you
[Music]